godzilla vs kong is now available to
watch in theaters
and on hbo max naturally a film about
two giant monsters duking it out is
going to have a few leaps of logic
here are some plot holes in the film
that you may not have noticed
the iteration of king kong we see in the
crossover was first introduced in 2017's
kong
skull island this version of the
character was one of the biggest
audiences he'd seen to date
only being beaten in height by his 1962
counterpart in king kong vs godzilla
kong measures an impressive 104 feet in
height
via screen rant that movie may have been
set in the 1970s but
kong has gone through quite the growth
spurt over the last 50
years materials from the film indicate
that in godzilla vs kong
the ape now measures at his tallest he's
ever been
on the big screen at 335
feet the series does try to offer an
explanation for this with an
old interview from producer alex garcia
saying how kong was an adolescent in
skull island and that he'd be doing some
growing between the two films
there's even a line in skull island
where a character mentions how kong's
going to keep growing
you don't want to wake up the big one
how big is it it's bigger
it wiped out his whole family kong is
the last of his kind but he's still
growing
however that still doesn't explain the
scene where we see the skeletons of
kong's parents
and they're roughly the same size as he
is
it's possible his parents perished at
relatively young ages after kong was
born and that
the ape had simply outlived them by the
time the events of godzilla vs kong take
place
but even if he's the equivalent of a
teenager initially it still
doesn't make sense that he'd triple in
size simply going off of what
animal species produce it's not like 13
year old humans who are five feet tall
suddenly become over 15 feet when
they're in their 50s it's definitely a
jump
and just seems like an attempt to get
kong to where he's on equal footing with
godzilla
while dr eileen andrews transports kong
to antarctica there's another human
subplot where madison tries to get more
information about apex
from a conspiracy theorist podcast host
named
bernie bernie has gone to great lengths
to ensure his identity doesn't get out
to the masses but madison
is able to get some clues about who he
is by going to his
website after about 10 seconds of
research
madison comes across an episode
description where bernie explains how
he's able to avoid detection from
big brother for starters it's probably
not a good idea to let all of your
tricks be known if you really want to
stay hidden
secondly there are two words that allow
madison to find him
namely chinatown and bleach so
what does she do she and her buddy josh
travel to chinatown where they go to
various shops looking for someone who
sells a lot of bleach
they find that person and lo and behold
the teens are knocking on bernie's door
in no time it makes sense that bernie
would want to stay hidden
after all he's revealing dark secrets
about apex and as a powerful
corporation they could easily have him
killed if they knew who he was
but that just makes it all the weirder
that it was relatively easy to find him
if two kids could figure it out then
surely a huge
international company would have the
resources to locate him
back to the kong plotline dr andrews
puts together a crew to transport the
big ape to antarctica
so that he can lead them to hollow earth
with a potentially powerful energy
source that could help in the humans
fight against the titans
the entire time they're worried about
godzilla finding kong because the lizard
would want to battle for supremacy over
who gets to be the alpha over earth
as expected godzilla does in fact
show up and the two have an epic battle
at sea
in the process numerous boats and planes
are destroyed with
a lot of lives presumably lost after
godzilla goes away
believing kong is dead they call in
aerial support and have a ton of
helicopters come to transport kong the
rest of the way
wait was that an option all along
it's kind of like how people point out
how in the lord of the rings frodo and
sam could have just taken the eagles to
mordor instead of walking all the way
it's a well-known fact in this universe
that godzilla likes to hang out in the
oceans
so why would they put a beast that
directly challenges the lizard
out in the open like that fuel would
certainly be a factor but there must
have been some kind of flight path that
they could have taken that would have
allowed
all of the aircraft to fuel up before
continuing on the quest
at the very least it seems like an
option worth pursuing before placing
kong in the worst
scenario imaginable hollow earth is a
mythical place in the monster verse
where things are more primordial
it's the whole reason they take kong to
antarctica in the first place because
that's where a portal to this realm is
located
not only that but the humans require
specialized aerial vehicles so that
they can survive the intense
gravitational shifts involved with going
from
regular earth to this new area and then
godzilla just atomic blasts his way to
the center of the earth with no problem
after all the work of making sure they'd
be able to take kong to hollow earth
godzilla just makes another tunnel in
hong kong
in a way we understand why this was
necessary it would have taken up too
much time to have kong come
out of the antarctica portal and somehow
make his way to china
this provides easy access so that the
two titans can have their final battle
in an efficient manner
it just calls into question the sheer
power of godzilla's atomic breath
if it's able to plow through every
single layer of the earth withstand
intense gravitational changes
and break whatever geographical layers
exist within hollow earth then
he's powerful on an intense scale we
can't even begin to possibly found him
godzilla should have been able to melt
mechagodzilla right off the bat
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]